this one's very very very weird and
interesting Palantir has confidentially
filed a draft of its s-1 paperwork for
its plan IPO listing right and I don't
know how much you know about this
company I don't know how much you know
about this company on what they're doing
okay let me let me read you what this
company is about the founder of the
company co-founders is CEO Alex Karp
which if you want to pull up his picture
in the article I don't know if you have
the article or not
Alex Karp and venture capitalist Peter
Thiel okay from the Mafia from the Mafia
and as you look into their business
model let me read you their business
model and what they're doing everybody
is curious about these guys now watch
this I'll give you some numbers here to
put things in perspective as a privately
held company Palantir valuation is to be
anywhere by the way most people have
never heard about this company before
Palantir company is estimated to be
anywhere between 11 to 41 billion
dollars
Wow somewhere in there pending on who is
estimating pitchbook pegs its valuation
at twenty billion dollars now you want
to know their business model
here's their business model you ready
for this here's a business model their
business model is plan tears software
allows law enforcement to enter a
license plate number Kai stop to enter a
license plate number and quickly get an
itinerary of the routes and places the
vehicle has traveled let me read it one
more time Gary this software allows the
law enforcement to enter a license plate
number and quickly get an itinerary of
the routes and places you have traveled
police can also use it to map out family
and business relationships this
technology Palantir technology has also
been used in New Orleans for predictive
policing what was that movie by the way
back in the days 15 years ago now
predicted before somebody was gonna
commit a crime do you remember that
movie or no Tom Cruise mine ordered
order right okay so here's a movie now
there's the technology Palantir
technology has allowed has also been
used in New Orleans for predictable
according to the verge a practice that
has been shown to increase surveillance
and arrest in communities of color now
let me continue in and I'll pose the
question say say this technology is
available say this technology can track
and minimize 50% of crimes in America
hear me out
let me finish the question 50% of the
crimes that we have in America if this
technology can prevent 50% of the folks
that died last year
from crimes is it worth the technology
for America to use the answer is hell to
the no that's right a preacher just said
hell no that's why to the no I'm gonna
tell you why I believe it was Jefferson
that said this he said you never choose
safety over freedom because if you do
you don't deserve either one of them
ladies and gentlemen this is what I
preach this is what I've been saying for
a very long time we're heading towards a
police state if it's not China it's
gonna be our own government that is
going to out technolog our out
technology us if you would if they have
the ability to track everything that we
do okay I don't even think that police
should be able to randomly run license
plates okay there has to be some sort of
limitations on us this is why I'm afraid
of us getting rid of of currency the
minute that you get rid of any sort of
monetary currency paper currency now
what do you do that means that you have
to digitize every single transaction
that means that there's no more privacy
when we don't have any more privacy that
means that ever everything about our
life can be known one of our rights is a
right to privacy this is something that
the Supreme Court has already instituted
that you and I have a right to privacy
the minute that that everything's
digital we no longer have that that that
rights so do I think that a police
officer should be able who's not even
elected official that's a higher person
do do I believe that a police officer
should be able to know everything about
you this technology is the kind of stuff
that scares the living crap out of me
pal
I think number one Thomas Jefferson was
right number two I think Josh fear Stein
is right but I also think it's happening
straight up as much as you want to
preach about this all this trackability
digital whereabouts this is all
happening
look what Tesla's doing look at the
mirrors doing it's all about the data
didn't you say that yourself it's all
about today it's all about the data baby
I want to send more data in my life it's
happening bro
so Rogan Corp just gave $50 and says
jesus is coming son open your eyes Adam
specifically to you all thank you
brother thank you I wish many blessings
and I mean let me read a little bit more
Palantir also works closely with the US
government and law enforcement agencies
counting the FBI CIA Department of
Defense amongst its customers by the way
it's been around since 2003 so it's not
like a five ten year old company it's 17
years it also has boasted about the good
that it does especially as pertaining to
its works with government agencies
previously CEO Alex Karp said that he
hears about foiled terrorist attacks in
Europe almost every week so he said
about they carry actor prevent terrorism
I'm just telling I'm reading they take
it out on the paper let me finish this
however Palantir has found itself
scrutinized for its dealings with
immigration and customs enforcement the
US agency responsible for enforcing
Donald Trump's crackdown on undocumented
immigrants in the country WNYC reported
in 2019 that ice agents use the
company's app in the field during
workplace rates your boy I'm asked your
motive as they are and we can argue
immigration we can do all this stuff I
don't care if it's ice or the police
force ladies and gentlemen this is scary
this is us moving towards what China is
doing to their citizens and being able
to read their their faces tell exactly
where they're at what there's three
cameras for every Chinese citizen every
look this is sky I don't get how people
don't understand says Orwellian this is
1984 literally living right in front of
our eyes we are living in a movie right
now
is it gonna happen though not if I have
anything to do
about it and I think that people need to
vote any sort of person that would
Institute this the hell out of Honor
what happened is if that person that's
instituting this is Donald J Trump I
will I will stand here and I will say
this if Donald Trump wants to institute
an invasion to the right of privacy and
that's to go against the Constitution I
say vote him the hell out to it and I
can happen I play devil's and any judge
let me play devil's advocate let me play
and by the way just so you know we're on
the same side position-wise but let me
play devil's advocate and tell me what
you think about this so do you remember
when Nancy Pelosi bashed Trump for
building the wall do you remember when
she said that okay and then they went to
showed the fact that her entire house
walls walls around it right okay now let
me flip it on you so if you live in a
20,000 square foot house on five acres
you got three dogs six kids you buy the
water
you travel a lot you're gonna put a
camera system in your house galore
oh well yeah yeah yeah yeah we put a
camera system in your house in or on my
house on the exterior yes so you're
gonna put a camera like you would put
camera to see every angle so when you're
gone you can see it right yes or no yes
okay it is it not essentially this is
your home land and this is a form knob
okay so tell me that I'm just again I'm
being a devil's advocate so tell me what
you think about okay so there is a huge
difference between public property and
private property that's private property
rights the thing about the public domain
it's owned by the American citizens not
the government ladies and gentlemen let
me remind you this the government does
not give us rights they were there to
protect our rights which means that the
public domain the public domain is owned
by the public we are supposed to be able
to freely move about move about our
public domain with the expectation of
the right to privacy this is
constitutional there's a huge difference
between private property me putting up
cameras on my own private property and
me thinking that a police officer
whoever it is has the right to run
computer searches on Who I am
well pet so let me ask you this why is
it then that a police officer is not
even allowed to ask me
constitutional he's not allowed to ask
me for identification unless I was
suspected of a crime go watch any of the
videos this is a lot of people that
people don't realize an officer has to
give you a reason as to why they are
asking you to produce ID you don't have
to produce ID for them there's tons of
people that play this out on on YouTube
and I'm not one of these guys that just
wants to go up and be a pain in the butt
and try to challenge these cops but I'm
telling you it's because you have an
expect and expected right to privacy the
same thing should revolve around facial
recognition and then being able to tell
bro if you really read this article look
at all the stuff that they're saying
there you'll be able to tell all of your
family members your business Society
knows everything about sure I've read
the article I understand it but I'm just
curious to know what their way they're
gonna pitch it to you because if if
we're being told cyber war is what's
gonna happen bio warfare is gonna happen
if that's the direction that they're
going to you know do you want them to be
able to track these types of things
before doctor for example let me let me
go a step deeper here by the way is it
fair to say that coronavirus gave a
playbook to the entire world of how to
shut down the entire country or is that
is that a fair assessment okay so so let
me let me go a different direction you
got six kids okay we run a business here
together right we run a good company
we're doing what we're doing here okay
if if this was able to detect somebody
bringing a virus through the airport say
if this was able to bring case number
one they could say nope stop turn the
plane around go back if this thing can
go deeper it's only two thousand
seventeen years if they go ten more
years with technology and advanced it if
this could prevent something like that
that even viruses couldn't paint gonna
make it to the country would you be open
to the advancement of this technology
yeah so there there is a huge difference
between you reading the facial
recognition of a person and knowing
everything about them okay between you
doing it to your citizens and you doing
it to somebody that's coming in from
outside of the country the people that
are coming in from outside of the
country do not have the same rights as
an American citizen
it's a huge difference between you doing
it from something that's showing up from
a foreign flight and walking through the
other thing that you're doing what one
we should know everything about anybody
that steps foot on them on American soil
okay which is why we obviously have
immigration checkpoints at all of our
borders okay now let me tell you what I
believe is unconstitutional and I think
that this is going to become an issue at
some point I do not believe that
immigration checks within the US are
constitutional I do not believe that you
have the right so if you've ever driven
so from say Phoenix over to San Diego if
you go along I ate there our immigration
checkpoints you can technically pull up
and tell them that you don't consent to
a search bubble bla you don't have the
right to stop an American citizen within
our borders and boundaries and ask for
immigration status so I'm one of the few
conservatives and Republicans out there
that take a little bit of a different
approach on how we should be able to ask
people of their immigration status like
or at least to make them produce let me
go a different direction let me go from
there let me go a differentdating stay
with me on this on the same exact taco
by the way again put a thumbs up let's
see if we can do right now we're at what
we're at 1100 let's see if we can get 2
2013 7 t1 we're close to getting to
4,000 mama take a different angle here
mother I want to hear your thoughts a
small comment below on what you think
about this we just got a hundred pounds
why have none of you watched or read the
minutes from event 201 which took place
September last year everything you they
played out is playing out headed by
Davos and John Hopkins University we
will take a look at it can you pull that
up and put that as something for us to
look at afterwards but let me give you
my point here here's my point here no
pull it up on your end just make a note
of it don't distract on a background
okay so what we just talked about right
now is the ability to go in during
access information to you that you don't
want to have the privacy fine when
Facebook and MySpace first came out how
quickly did you get on MySpace and
Facebook okay so I see where you're
going on and stay with me just play a
lot fast yeah how fast I mean days
seriously are you the same way no I was
not no no okay so wait let me get this
one when myspace came out you were on
myspace within a month I mean I was
single you know I'm saying okay single
and ready to mingle I'm now married and
ver
did you get unfriend well when Facebook
came the Facebook came out you were on
the moment you found out about it and
people sent you an email you like yeah
okay
okay Phil okay fine hi did you as well
or no how quickly did you get on the
social media I mean you're a kid
Louise how are you yeah okay 25 so you
were old enough how quickly did you get
on facebook and myspace bandwagon okay
how soon did you accept the fact that
Facebook's gonna be a part of your
lifestyle to post pictures of what you
eat where you travel where you go
tagging here's location didn't you
initially think this is kind of weird
didn't you initially think it was
confirm me I'm a private guy I'm like
wait a minute there used to be another
app or you would put a pin that you
would go to a restaurant and they would
check to see how many restaurants you
went an eight what was that one help
not Yale no it was another app and it
was it blew up by the way for like three
years you would go and you would
literally say I'm at this restaurant
then I'm at this restaurant and would
say oh you're a traveler you're a bar
hopper it was a big a bother if you guys
remember this app comment below because
I'm going in a direction with this okay
I wasn't comfortable disclosing my life
on Facebook so I didn't get on YouTube
and Facebook early I wasn't comfortable
going on social media talking about my
personal different posts and pictures I
thought it was very weird but eventually
you know what happened I eventually sat
there and said okay this is pretty
interesting you yourself said you're not
comfortable with some like this because
all the data is gonna be shared and you
have a you know a Fitbit and all the
data is gonna be sure people know
exactly or such okay now let me go to
the next part here
I talked to chip Wilson chip Wilson is
the founder of Lululemon guys worth 4
billion dollars they just bought Mira by
the way for 500 million dollars that
technology we looked at right you know
what he sent the interview to me he said
20 years from now everybody's gonna be
physically in shape
Foursquare exactly 4 score was a
technology that's what it was ok he said
in 20 years
everyone's gonna be in shape I said what
do you mean he says in 20 years every
body is gonna be in shape I said I don't
understand what you mean by this
he says everyone's gonna be in shape I
said tell me why says here's why because
20 years from now everyone's gonna wear
smart clothes so what smart clothes
he says smart clothes you wear is gonna
tell you everything about your body
everything about your body everything
about your body you want to know your
blood pressure your test style
everything about your body on what you
need to do you stop eating you're eating
too much that's enough that's enough
water drink a little bit more water not
enough this is too much carbs this is
everything about your water is gonna be
persistent 20 years it's not gonna be a
big deal to be in shape it's gonna be a
big deal if you're not in shape
interesting perspective on what he says
right thanks sir
okay so just just a little side note my
father and I actually invested into a
broad company that literally will tell
you if you have breast cancer
so it's so it's very you know that's
kind of lined with would wait this is
course it detects if there's any hot
masses and it watches you from day to
day got it okay so so this goes to the
next level do you think gradually within
time just like we accepted the lifestyle
of social media and Facebook and telling
the world where we are eating yeah I
mean tell them people I'm at the
restaurant come and take care take care
of me if you need I'm at this place and
we've gradually accepted given our data
here to a company like this we're
gradually accepted
you know using a smart clothes don't you
think we're gradually a company like
this is banking on one thing because
when I process at a company like pelant
II is banking on what thing eventually
people didn't accept us and will be a
truly eternal company so so you see my
program yeah of course
their various to me a huge difference
between giving your information like
when I signed up for MySpace I had to go
through a bunch of terms and conserva
sand in and conditions that let's be
honest none of us read but we all knew
that we were giving up our privacy right
okay so we consented we checked the box
and we consider to give our prior our
information to a private company the
same way that I give my health
information to a private doctor I don't
want the government having my health
information so I'm giving it to a
private doctor a private practice
private hospital blah blah blah so it's
one thing for me to give my information
to a company because there's a
reasonable expectation of privacy which
is why there's also been Patti's huge
deals between the FBI and say Apple so
there's a a doctrine a philosophical
doctrine called piercing the veil okay
so the minute that you pierce the veil
and anything it now opens it up for
there to be a whole flood of say you
pierce the veil and suing a tobacco
company you win there's a million more
lawsuits that are coming because you
pierce the veil so there is a huge fight
right now between the government and
companies like Google Apple bla bla bla
in being a the government being able to
access data that is held by private
companies okay so this is this is a huge
huge issue right now because the minute
that they're able to pierce the veil it
is all over for us so it's one thing
I'll just give a quick summary it's one
thing for me to give Fitbit my my heart
rate alright but I don't want the
government knowing everything about it
that's why I have a private contract
with Fitbit the moment that I sign up I
have to hit terms and conditions I'll
give it to a private company but I don't
want the government happening it I'm
just gonna weigh in on this number one
kudos to you you I mean you know your
stuff brother that's super impressive
stuff just a way that you think but what
I'll tell you is this for everyone Josh
fierce ton that knows his stuff in and
out no way you're not looking over me
there's literally a million people in
America they're like yes I'm its
customer but it's not to say most people
don't understand the ins and outs of the
law hear me out here it's because people
don't teach the constitutional schools
anymore - Shane - Shane but the point is
for everyone like you there's a million
people in like alright click accept cool
follow me cool sign up for Facebook sign
up for Instagram sign up for tick-tock
China's following me I don't give a [ __ ]
tick-tock it up being boned Bing bong or
dancing now I hear what you're saying
bro for sure I just don't think I think
people are so comfortable these days
with their stuff being out there you
asked about going on Facebook you know I
didn't go on Facebook in 2005 because I
was single and I was hooking up with a
couple different girls - close your ear
muffs and I didn't want the one girl
that I was kind of with knowing that the
other girl that like these days you
can't hide that look what did I bring up
at lunch there used to be people who had
a family here multiple families in
Dallas and they had a family in San
Antonio that are they were to go work in
San Antonio next thing you know like
dad's away for the week it was easy to
have
multiple families these days hmm you
can't you can't hide anything you
appointed Russian yes people are very
comfortable putting their stuff out
there these days for every Josh fear
Stein there's a million Americans who
are like click click accept bingo so we
know one thing if Konya supports
polygamy he's got us both but go ahead
out hi I'm looking for one night woman
or a Thai boy we good yeah I I don't
know I think I think we have accepted
more than you think we have oh no no I
think I'm not arguing me I just said
that it's wrong oh I don't think I don't
disagree that it's wrong I don't
disagree that it's wrong but I think we
have accepted more and look for for
instance this debate I'm giving you is
the debate you guys give me to say you
know what Andrew yang came up with which
is what Andrew yang said what the fact
that the thousand-dollar
automation universal basic income etc
not much I would say Pat's gonna happen
Tony Robbins said it Elon Musk said it a
bunch of geysers I'm like I don't think
that's the case animation I don't buy
into it I don't buy into that part right
but you have an argument to say no we're
going there because here's what's gonna
happen with you know innovation and
automation and that it's not even
innovation it's automation that's gonna
put a lot of people I'm saying
innovation American innovation is gonna
by automation but but what I'm saying
what this is my point with this is I
think we if there's a tipping point of
accepting in trues you know people
intruding in your life and the decisions
you make we're not at 30 percent we're
at 55 percent but let me take it on one
one step further okay and people can
think this is science-fiction all you
want but guys this is freaking happening
what's gonna happen now okay so my
issues not with with with Facebook
taking my info my issue is with Facebook
turning around partnering with the
government to use it against me my
question to you is this bad now that
Elon Musk has already told us that his I
think it's called neural Inc all right
yeah yeah with now now that his neural
link is gonna plug into your head the
fiber optics are gonna go into your
brain all right so now where you can
have these simulations that you would
have never thought
even possible what's gonna happen now
when you on must neuro-link partners
with the government and now they have
access not even into our facial
recognition and guys it this isn't
science fiction this is right around the
corner what happens when now they can
see into your freaking thoughts or even
worse control your thoughts and people
are gonna say I'm like Eddie Bravo over
there on Rogan but I'm telling you guys
this is something that we have to look
at now we have to set our principles and
guidelines now because this sort of
stuff is around the corner and the
problem is we don't know how to deal
with it this is brand new area and this
is a brand new area because I want you
focusing more on this than political
stuff this is UK you got a gift for this
my friend I type I think most of our
audience is gonna go huh none on this
you're saying no I think we have we are
but what do you what are you talking
abou there let me tell you why because I
Pat believed in the vision of value
tainment and I'm gonna tell you why sure
I believe as you and I have set down
that we have a responsibility this is
why I'm not running for Congress right
now this is why you are exiting business
in order to go and affect America
I would not be here at value taemin and
if I did not believe that we cannot turn
this tide and I'm gonna tell you how we
do it we educate the next generation we
take a generation of young people a
generation of kids that right now are so
caught up in entertainment that they're
not getting any value they're just
getting pure propaganda through
entertainment Disney's doing it Amazon's
doing it Netflix is doing it all of the
liberal left and elite and not not just
the left it's even on the right but
everybody is funneling their bull crap
into our kids minds what I say is value
tainment does something different we I'm
not gonna divulge all of our plans but
you and I have talked about what we can
do with with education you and I have
talked about what we can do in the
schools we have to educate these kids
about number one what their civic duties
and responsibilities are number two what
their rights as an American are and what
their responsibilities to their families
to the future Americans are if we can do
those things and we can wrap it up in a
pretty package like shout out value
attainment kids which is going to be
coming soon when we can show these kids
who they are as Americans week we can
change the world I do not believe that
hope is lost
man I sound like I should be running for
good you're on fire right now I just
want the people at home to know you are
on fire this for the first time ever I
have no objections to what you're saying
it's diet coke needs to pay us that's
the vision that is the vision of what
we're gonna be for sure it's no question
about it
[Music]